[موسيقى]
المنحدرات الصخرية
والحصون الشهيرة في
دوبروفنيك تبدو مألوفة تمامًا للناس في جميع
أنحاء العالم الذين لم يسبق لهم الذهاب إلى
هنا من قبل ، لقد
دمرت اللعبة التي
أخبرتك أنني لا أريد أن ألعب
ماذا عن ذلك واحد
هناك لملايين الأشخاص هذا  هو
هبوط الملك من مسلسل hbo game of
thrones ، يأتي الآثم قبل أن
تتمسك ، دعه بلا خطيئة
أكثر حدة مما يبدو عليه ،
انظر إلى أن
هذه كانت وجهة نظر تستحق التسلق
لملك العالم
[تصفيق]
حسنًا ،
فيلم خاطئ أنا غافل إنني
أمشي  بعد الدليل الذي يعرض
مشاهد لعبة العروش للسائح ،
قد أكون الشخص الوحيد على هذا الكوكب
الذي لم يشاهد العرض ،
كل ما أراه هو دوبروفنيك الجميل
منذ وصولي إلى هنا ، أصبحت
مهووسًا بهذا اليخت الضخم
ولدت
في المياه خارج البلدة القديمة
دوبروفنيك ، أعرف الآن
أن اسمها هو
Shakarezada وهو إما رابع أو خامس
أكبر يخت ضخم في العالم
اعتمادًا على تعريفك
لليخوت
الشراعية مواثيق
العطلات للكرواتيين  هذه العلاقة مع
البحر أعمق بكثير ،
يجب أن أعرض المساعدة هنا ولكني
لا أعرف ما أفعله
اليوم ، كل ما يدور حوله
يمكنك تشغيل المحرك إذا كنت تريد ، لذا
فهو هنا سهل جدًا لذا يمكنني فقط
أوه  يمكنني أن أجعلها أفضل ، لذا فهي
تبدأ بالقوة ،
حسنًا ، الآن انتظر وابدأ والآن
لا شيء على
الإطلاق ، لا شيء على الإطلاق أخبرتك
أنني أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك ، سأترك القفز إلى داردو
إنه جميل ونحن فقط على
طريقتنا ،
انظر إلى هذا ،
إنه رائع ،
إنه جميل ، أليس كذلك ، أعني أنه
لا أحد يقود القارب ولكن
يبدو أننا نخرج جيدًا ،
أنا سعيد لرؤيتك مرة أخرى ، نعم كنت
جاهزًا ، كنت مستعدًا
لحركة المشهد للقارب
وأنت تعرف ما حدث بعد ذلك ،
ربما كنت قد شعرت بإغراء قيلولة
بعد ذلك فقط
عندما تشعر
بالسلام والهدوء عندما تفتح
الزنزانة وتسمع فقط مثل
الرياح والأمواج وزوجين من الطيور
تشعر بالراحة
والسعادة.
سأقول السعادة متى فعلت
نقع في حب البحر
بالنسبة لنا دائمًا مثل جزء من لقمة العيش ،
فقط تذهب على متن قارب وتذهب
للسباحة وهذا هو جزء من الحمض النووي لدينا
لأننا نتمتع
بهذا الساحل وبالبحر وكل
شيء وأنت  فقط بحاجة
إلى استخدامه